les filles ragots c'est mon pote marc
salut salut moi c'est nicky elle c'est
ça les regarde par ici vraiment carstens
je pense qu'elle voulait simplement
vivre leur vie à voir la vie dans tout
le monde est stone organise une grosse
teuf abega ce soir parce qu'elle habite
part on pourrait entrer je suis pas trop
chaud je veux aller c'est par ici
j'ai envie d'une europe cette femme elle
est très jolie
c'est nouveau on avait tellement de
trucs fashion
trop mignon comme ça j'entends des
hélicoptères on est à l air est un peu
de faire ta peureux du stress c'est pas
qu'on soit sûrs et la police enquêtent
sur les liens qui existeraient entre les
différents cambriolages d'hollywood où
les états unis ont une fascination
perverse
on les bonnie and clyde tout ça se
résume à une série de mauvais choix
moi je le redis
tu peux pas prendre le chien mais ce
chien m'adore
je crois profondément à la notion
écumant les événements ne sont pas
arrivés par hasard ça a été une leçon
essentielle pour moi je me suis ouverte
à une plus grande spiritualité
génériques
pourquoi pas devenir chef d'état vous
avez parlé à certaines des victimes
j'ai parlé à toutes les victimes oui
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit l'insee